hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video hat hofft natürlich
geht es gut ich stehe hier an meinem
tisch im büro und das heißt eigentlich
nur einzelner kann nur eins heißen wir
müssen mal wieder was auspacken so blöd
ist nicht spaßig habe vor einiger zeit
was bestellt auf amazon zwei zuschauer
haben mich gleichzeitig darauf
hingewiesen ich kann euch gerne mal hier
den geschäftsverlauf einblenden und ich
habe mir das angeguckt und dachte mir ja
wahrscheinlich wird das eben den flop
aber es besteht schon mit ganz ganz
kleine geringe möglichkeit dass man
vielleicht mal glück hat oder vielleicht
sind das ja auch wirklich geile sachen
trotzdem habe ich mich aber auch sehr
gewundert dass man überhaupt so etwas
über amazon verkaufen kann weil
eigentlich sind die echt ein bisschen
kritisch auch auf ebay kannst du nicht
mal so missouri boxen irgendwie sache
nicht klar definiert zum verkaufen das
ging aber ich habe für 80 euro dieses
paket gekauft das gibt es jetzt leider
nicht mehr warum auch immer ein bisschen
schade aber ich habe meine ich auf
meinem mac pro x und screenshot davon
von dem angebot sollte so sieht übrigens
die bezaubernde dame aus von der ich
diese mystery box gekauft habt also
zumindest ist es auch im foto so schön
oder da hat man doch gleich viel mehr
vertrauen in die ganze sache und jetzt
lesen neben den text dazu vor
dies ist eine überraschungsbox für
elektronik alle mit reebok elektronik
sind brandneu 60% zufällig größer gleich
zahlungsweg 30 prozent chance dreifacher
zahlungs wert prozent chance 10 eine
zahlung 2 prozent chance gewinnen sie
den mist im preis dies ist ein abenteuer
über mut und glück alle mystery box in
unserer überraschung box werden rem
ausgewählt was eine versuchung zu
überraschen ist einer mystery box wenn
sie zwei mystery boxen gleichzeitig
kaufte er in die zusätzliche belohnung
hätte ich das wahr gemacht
nichts ist ihr paket kann zusätzliche
nützliche und interessante elemente
enthalten für und so weiter und so fort
ich muss sagen ich finds echt heftig
dass amazon oder dass sie das über
amazon so verkaufen dass man eigentlich
ist es nicht erlaubt das angebot gibt es
jetzt auch nicht mehr beziehungsweise es
wurde beendet wahrscheinlich aus dem
wohn ich hab keinen run also mal sehen
vielleicht haben wir hier jetzt gleich 1
800 euro produkt
bestimmte also nur elektronik drin sein
smart watches mobile phones laptops habe
ich glaube ich auch gelesen im wert von
50 bis maximal 800 euro also den
zehnfachen wert den man bezahlt klar
irgendwann wird er bestimmt der haken
sein also ich habe jetzt nicht die
größten erwartungen aber ich bin mal
gespannt und es ist auch ein bisschen
wird dass das aus china kommt ich habe
mich gestern voll gewundert weil ich
habe schon gedacht das ist ein bisschen
größer ist es ist auch nicht schwer
deswegen wirkt fünf kilo unsere richtige
absender schädler auch gar nicht drauf
das ist von jung express logistics das
ist aber eher so ein chinesischer
logistikpartner und kein amazon händler
also alles auf jeden fall ein bisschen
wird begrüßten gespannt wir machen auch
vor noch eine sache das habe ich
vergessen dass huawei smartphone dieses
wunderschöne gerät hier pur beim smart
221 das habe ich noch verlost ich habe
total vergessen dass aufzulösen tut ein
bisschen leid deswegen hier hat der
jubilar kommentar ein grillfest
glückwunsch du hast gewonnen und gehört
nicht weil die melden oder du dich bei
mir wird immer dann bekommst du das
zugeschickt viel spaß damit okay der
mama oder auch auf jeden fall sehr
interessant dass das in seiner paypal
verpackung gekommen ist man ja das sieht
ja wunderschön aus ich bin ja wirklich
aktuell auch vom pech verfolgt
eigentlich oder das heißt vom pech
verfolgt mancher bin ja ein bisschen
irgendwann 300 euro für eben diese
koffer bezahlt die koffer unboxing es
waren ja auch gern keiner klopp oben
angekommen
das sind bestimmt ich würde es sind
bestimmt einfach wieder nur chinesische
drecks marken die kein mensch braucht
hh okay wir haben tatsächlich einfach
nur eine sache drin
sieht ja an sich gar nicht so schlecht
aus ich hatte heute morgen auf meinen go
pro koffer in der hand
der sieht so ähnlich aus es ist halt
leider ein bisschen recht also darüber
im video zu machen weil es ist halt
einfach nicht viele leute spannende
musik bitte ok kommt stocker wird das
muss irgendwas geist sein wer ich denke
mal der konzerte in die kommentare
schreiben
ihr habt doch 50 sagen wir zehn sekunden
zeit mehr steckt jedoch ein bisschen was
welche drin sein ich glaube es ist das
smart watch oder eventuell auch eine
action cam oder vielleicht hat auch
irgendwas was wertvoll ist wo man 3 2 1
eine drohne neuer die kann ich ja
wenigstens einmal testen
wir haben in dem mini drohne ok gar
nicht mal so weg also ja ich schaue ich
mir jetzt mal andeutete
ich kann mich gut daran erinnern als ich
noch in köln gebot habe habe ich mal die
kleinste drohne der welt getestet ich
glaube die wahl kleiner als diese hier
die hat sogar eine kamera dabei also
kann man auch draußen entspannt deine
aufnahmen machen instructions for you
missed geht und für euch die jetzt
allerdings mal hier drin testet und dann
vielleicht auch noch draußen schauen wir
mal was von wert das ding eigentlich hat
ich denke aber mal eigentlich nicht mehr
als 50 guck mal das ich schon an wir
müssen noch mit schirm batterien rein
oder na das war ja mal wieder klar dass
sich die batterien nicht habe naja ich
habe jetzt eh gleich feierabend dann
fahren wir mal in meine wohnung ich habe
das richtige modell ist und nicht
gefunden hier ist eins ist ungefähr
gleich aus das kostet 39 99 pakete ohne
auf jeden fall ist bleibt zusammen und
dann starten wir die zu hause bei mir im
wohnzimmer ich bin schon ewig keine
drohne hergeflogen den übergang würde
ich jetzt gern aber nutzen um einmal
danke zu sagen und zwar ein ergo tobt ja
die haben wir nämlich freundlicherweise
ist schon ein bisschen ins herz 23
monate mein büro ist ein bisschen
ausgestattet ich habe der elektrisch
verstellbaren schreibtisch von denen
ein schreibtischstuhl
doch die bildschirm haltung seht ihr
hier alles einmal eingeblendet mega
entspannt danke dafür schickt die
website von den ab die sache nicht alles
sehr sehr qualitativ hochwertig und die
haben wir damit auch wirklich sehr
geholfen gerade auf dem
schreibtischstuhl super super nice schon
so ein bisschen den rücken also zeigt
die beschreibung gehabt habe ich euch
sehr gut hier verlinkt und schaut da
gerne vorbei krones eingepackt ab nach
hause
leute was geht ich bin jetzt hier gerade
mal zusammen feld gefahren ich hatte ein
bisschen angst hier drinnen starten zu
lassen nicht dass wir irgendwas
simuliere ich bin schon so lang eine
drohne mehr geflogen ich hoffe das ding
geht gut ab da ja mal schauen wir müssen
jetzt gerade noch batterien rein
das ding ist jetzt aber an die drohne
dann würde ich sagen versuchen wir
lieber zu starken vom dach des g8 so
dass man sich sogar rein gar nichts mehr
ich habe gerade was das postauto
getroffen scheiße ist sie da abgestürzt
ich hoffe sie lebt noch
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hier bin ja
immerhin macht ihr spaß was ja das
wichtigste krone drohne
ich rufe drohne also hier ist sie
irgendwo abgestürzt da hinten steht mein
auto also das war schon eine gute
distanz ich glaube die hat nicht so viel
reichweite wo ist sie denn jetzt da
liegt sie ja entschuldigung da sind wir
wieder
ich teste erstmal wie hoch die gegner
durch ihr könnt das hier sehen bekomme
ich lasse jetzt einfach mal nach oben
steigen die ist jetzt schon so würde ich
mal sagen 20 meter wo ich hoffe ihr
könnt ihr sehen auf der kamera ich habe
gerade meine kleine kamera dabei oder
hinten ist die straße da oben ist ja
warte mal scheiße dies zu weit weg eine
die viel zu weit weg und die
gelegentlich auf die straßenbahn vor
alter junge was ist das für eine
amokdrohung ich habe gerade noch
hinbekommen dass sie können dann sagen
wir mal so 50 meter weiter hinter diesen
beton dingern ist also eine
schnellstraße und des brücken wald
gestürzt und du hast keine kontrolle
darüber zu geben ob wiederfinde
ohne scheiß ich find ihn nicht mehr und
das war wirklich gefährlich also ich
hätte niemals gedacht dass so ein
kleines piesting so 200 meter distanz
schafft und du kannst dir einfach nicht
kontrollieren wenn du nach rechts
touristik die nach links das sind
einfach solche schrott finger also wenn
ihr euch so billig drohen kauft passt
auf und mit ihr damit fliegt also ohne
scheiß das kann echt gefährlich werden
ich habe zum beispiel auf die magic pro
und hin medicare und damit ist halt was
ganz anderes die kannst du perfekt
kontrollieren
aber bei diesen kleinen dingern ist es
unmöglich also am besten die finger
davon lassen
ich hatte gerade echt ein bisschen angst
dass startet der tag auf jeden fall mit
einem guten adrenalin-kick also die
drohne ist jetzt irgendwo in dem
waldstück da hinten die werde ich glaube
ich auch nicht wiederfinden ist
natürlich ein bisschen doof ich jetzt
gleich noch mal
ich habe mir das video hat euch trotzdem
halbwegs gefallen auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht das krasseste bekommen habe und
wenn ich die drohne wieder finde ich
schenke ich dir irgendwann von euch
kommentieren aber wahrscheinlich finde
ich sie nicht aber nur weil neben mir
verspricht sie nicht einzusetzen wir
sehen uns die tage wieder abonniert
super gern den kanal
lasst doch nach oben da würde ich mich
sehr freuen und yahoo drei leute